[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
it's johnny depp versus amber heard she
called him an old fat man it's
it's insane your excuse ma'am you can
have your excuse the highlights of week
one's multi-million dollar defamation
suit plus jennifer and james crumbly
petition the court for a lower bond but
are they still considered a flight risk
and a florida defendant is given a
chance to speak this was a personal
catastrophe
in everybody's life in my family
including myself
i maintain my innocence when the jury
comes down to a unanimous decision after
a short deadlock but first with regard
to count one attempted murder of lauren
cataract what is your verdict not guilty
by reason of insanity
another verdict is handed down in the
ex-olympian attempted murder case law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long time daily i'm
your host brian buckmark after about 18
hours of deliberation over the course of
about four days a verdict is handed in
in the attempted murder case of
ex-olympian michael barisson in new
jersey
barriston was found not guilty by reason
of insanity on thursday for the 2019
attempted murder of lauren canorack and
was acquitted of attempted murder on
lauren canorax then boyfriend robert
goodwin defense attorneys argued
barristone feared for his life at the
time of the shooting and suffered from
mental health issues ahead of the
shooting barrisone a former olympian was
training canorax in dressage horseback
riding while she was living on his
property in a string of several 9-1-1
calls days leading up to the shooting
barriston said he tried to evict
canarack and goodwin kanirak in turn
told dispatchers she was being harassed
over the course of several weeks jurors
heard from cataract and goodwin as well
as several witnesses on barristone's
mental health that combined with other
evidence in the case led to the jury's
decision thursday afternoon the verdict
is read before the court
with regard to count one attempted
murder of lauren canorack what is your
verdict not guilty by reason women said
with regard to count two
attempted murder
of
robert goodwin what is your verdict sir
with regard to count two the lesser
included offense of aggravated assault
upon
robert goodwin what is your verdict
on count three possession of a weapon
for an unlawful purpose to use against
the person of lauren canora what is your
verdict not guilty by reason
and with regard to count four possession
of a weapon for an unlawful purpose what
is your verdict
lon crying spoke with canorax former
attorney on friday he was on the phone
with counteract when she was shot he
tells us his reaction to the verdict
initially i i was shocked
um
i i could not conceive of how a jury
could find anything but
that barristone attempted to kill warren
then i thought about it and um
i kind of understand it now
the act itself of of
shooting a gun at somebody
most people would think is an
intentional act right and and at the
time that he pulled the trigger he
intended to pull the trigger but what
was in his head and i think what the
jury
decided they had to have decided
was that such an act could only have
been done by somebody who did not have
the mental capacity to understand that
it was wrong
joining us today is law and crime
analyst tammy allison and co-host terry
austin tammy no self-defense argument
but not guilty of attempted murder
against goodwin how does that make sense
you know this is shocking i'm just as
shocked as the attorney was but you know
i always talk about how the defendant's
attorneys their job is to raise doubt so
the jury going back asking the judge
questions
perhaps that was what they were
discussing what the defense raised not
defense but some of these other
mitigating factors that could have
caused this defendant to act this way
that resulted in this unfortunate death
but doubt is what is needed with the
very high burden of proof that the
prosecution has to meet which is beyond
a reasonable doubt he intended to murder
the victim in this case yeah
i guess the the victims who testify in
this case for the attempted murder
charges didn't persuade the jury enough
terry what happens to barriston when
he's found not guilty by reason of
insanity after shooting can iraq twice
so you know brian under new jersey law
there's what's called a cruel hearing
and it's based on a new jersey supreme
court case the judge said that he was
going to schedule that within 30 days as
he's required to do but when you're
found not guilty by reason of insanity
you're entitled to a hearing to
determine whether or not you still pose
a threat to yourself or to others and so
they schedule this for may 17th and he
has to be there he has to come in person
and they will do this hearing they will
determine they'll have evidence to
determine whether or not he is insane or
not and whether or not he needs to go
into the department of health and if so
for how long he could theoretically be
deemed rational at this point and not go
at all but i think he'll go and then
come out at a later date yeah of course
we'll give you updates as that hearing
comes up here on the law on crime
network still ahead on law and crime
daily o'vernick has returned in the tote
family quadruple murder trial and later
this malicious lie that she started and
she created and it's gone out the door
and around the world
hollywood heavyweights johnny depp and
amber heard go head-to-head in a
defamation suit here in testimony from
week one ahead
[Music]
welcome back another verdict is decided
by a florida jury on thursday as former
physical therapist anthony toad is found
guilty of the murders of his wife three
children and the killing of the family
dog
prosecutors say tote drugged smothered
and stabbed his wife megan his three
children alexander tyler and zoe and the
family dog breezy in december 2019. they
say he lived alongside their bodies for
weeks after they died toad initially
confessed to the killings to police then
later blamed his wife saying she killed
the children then herself after a few
hours of deliberating thursday afternoon
the jury told the judge they were at a
deadlock and couldn't come to unanimous
decision then the judge ordered them to
continue deliberating about 15 minutes
later they came back with a unanimous
decision guilty on all charges of murder
in the first degree and animal cruelty
for the death of the family dog
verdict has to count one
we the jury find the defendant guilty of
first-degree murder as charged in the
indictment
verdict as to count two
we the jury find the defendant guilty of
first-degree murder as charged in the
indictment
verdict as to count three we the jury
find the defendant guilty of
first-degree murder as charged in the
indictment
verdict as to count four
we the jury find the defendant guilty of
first-degree murder as charged in the
indictment
verdict as to count five we the jury
find the defendant guilty of cruelty to
animals
ahead of sentencing megan told to aunt
had the opportunity to speak then as the
defendant stood up and pleaded to the
judge his attorney attempted to stop him
several times
this was a personal
catastrophe
in everybody's life in my family
including myself
i maintain my innocence
i love my wife
i love my children i was not there the
night my children died what to do
i judge carson doesn't have the
authority to overtrain no i understand
but i i need to let him know
i'm sorry
i love my wife
i love my kids they were first and
foremost in my life
i did not do this
my kids and my wife were everything to
me they were the center of my universe
tote was sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole terry
we know the sentence was somewhat
mandatory based on the charge but what
was your reaction to toad's final words
in court
you know i'm so surprised that the judge
let him go on and on like that i'm glad
his attorney got up and said sit down he
tried to maintain his innocence explain
to the judge why he's not guilty and he
went through the on victim impact
statement almost line by line trying to
refute all the things she said including
the fact that he gained weight including
the fact that she he said that he was
controlling and and he tried to say he
wasn't controlling listen at the end of
the day the judge threw the book at him
it is mandatory life but he gave him
consecutive mandatory life and he even
added another year for the cruelty
against the dog so i'm glad the judge
basically made a statement with his
sentencing yeah you see the judge make a
statement there and then you see the
facts against him tammy at one point
though the jury was deadlocked what do
you think the jury may have been divided
on that caused that deadlock for such a
short period of time
you know perhaps the dog because at this
point everything else is pretty clear
and it seems as if as terry said you
know with the judge's consecutive
sentencing meaning that for each count
he has to serve a term of life not at
the same time concurrently the
difference is after the sentence of life
he has another sentence of life so um i
think the jury was really kind of
probably stuck on what to do with the
animal cruelty charge because everything
else seems pretty cut and dry yeah it's
interesting like i said came back after
15 minutes so obviously not that divided
something that can simply be resolved
after a few minutes thank you both for
the update in this the florida vs
anthony toad case coming up on law and
crime daily the parents of the accused
oxford high school shooter want their
bond lowered plus
you've been watching so you have seen
parts of this trial
yeah your excuse man you can have your
excuse
a shocking moment in the johnny depp and
amber heard defamation trial still ahead
we take a closer look at week one
[Music]
welcome back the parents of the accused
michigan high school shooter ask a judge
to lower their bond arguing they are
being unfairly portrayed as bad parents
jennifer and james crumbly maintain they
did not know their son would carry out a
mass shooting both parents are charged
with four counts of involuntary
manslaughter following the shooting
spree at oxford high school last
november prosecutors say their
15-year-old son ethan crumbly opened
fire in the school killing four students
and injuring others he faces charges of
first-degree murder assault with a
deadly weapon and terrorism now jennifer
and james crumbly request bond to be
lowered from five hundred thousand
dollars to a hundred thousand defense
attorneys for the couple argue they are
not a flight risk or a danger to the
public prosecutors pushed back though
saying the pair was on the run after
their initial charges but the crumbly
say they only left the oxford area for
their own safety the pair is due back in
court for a hearing next tuesday
sir it may not work to reduce their bail
but could the argument they just didn't
know their son would commit a mass
shooting win them the trial
well the argument they didn't know will
help them but i don't think it's going
to help them win the trial listen
they're charged with four counts of
involuntary manslaughter and basically
they're going to have to be able to
dispute the fact that their careless and
reckless actions actually contributed
and caused to the death that occurred
here and we we know absolutely from the
prosecution that they have evidence
going against that and going against the
parents there are two texts at least
that say that
ethan is ill and he wants to go to the
doctor that he told his parents they
ignored him he has a journal entry
frankly saying that he's going to shoot
up the school so i don't think the
parents are going to be able to
successfully claim that they didn't know
about it and these charges they're very
novel brian but if they succeed against
the parents it'll be a wake-up call to
take seriously mental health issues all
right so i'm glad we've got the only
attorney who has a federal clemency firm
in the country because i've made
thousands of bail arguments tammy but
i've never heard that being misportrayed
as a bad parent is a reason to reduce
bail do that argument make sense to you
it does not make sense at all like
where'd i do that at okay i've never
heard anyone make that type of argument
nobody cares at this point if you're
being portrayed as a bad parent or not
there are people that died here children
and this is something that every parent
across the country is the most fearful
of if their child is going to be at the
location where there is another student
that shoots up the school and these
parents here needed to come up with a
better argument if they wanted to reduce
or remove um their bond at this point
but i i don't know where they do that at
yeah a reduction of bail argument can be
made at any time uh so long as there's a
kind of change of circumstance i know
that's the typical language used but i
don't see a change of circumstance
that's going to help the crumbly parents
reduce their bail but of course we'll
keep eyes on this case as it continues
when we come back the multi-million
dollar defamation suit of johnny depp
first amber heard
that is something that is attached to
him now
which trickles down to his children
you know where i think that part
more than anything
is the part that has
bothered him
still ahead we bring you the highs and
lows from week one of the case
[Music]
welcome back in week one of johnny depp
versus amber heard we've heard shocking
allegations seeing witnesses break down
and others dismiss for watching media
coverage of the trial the lawsuit stems
from a 2018 washington post article
written by heard while depp's name was
not mentioned in the piece heard alleges
she is a victim of domestic abuse depp
argues he lost roles in both the harry
potter and pirates of the caribbean
franchises because of herds accusations
after that deb filed a defamation suit
against herd to the tune of 50 million
dollars heard countersued for a hundred
million dollars the case began on monday
of this week where a jury of seven
jurors and four alternates were seated
after only one day on tuesday opening
statements were presented revealing even
more striking accusations
mr deb would often retreat into
bathrooms lock the doors
wait out miss heard russian but his
leading just provoked her more you're
going to hear evidence that when mr duck
and miss her traveled together
his team routinely had to book an extra
room
for him
so that he had somewhere to go when his
herd
became enraged he rips off her nightgown
he has her jammed up against a bar he
has hurled bottles and bottles at her he
has dragged her across the floor on the
broken bottles in the liquor he has
punched her he has kicked her he tells
her he's gonna kill her he hates her
he's pounding at her pounding her and
then he penetrates her with a liquor
bottle
that's the johnny depp that you're going
to hear about in this case
johnny depp's sister was the first
witness called to the stand she told
jurors about the start and end of
death's relationship with her she says
her to file for divorce just days after
the death of depp's mother
what was your reaction
upon hearing from your brother
that he was going to marry miss her i
was
scared i was devastated actually that it
was uh it was going to happen as as a as
quickly as it was being pushed for i
actually tried to talk him into just
just waiting a little bit longer just a
little bit and not
not rushing how did you react initially
when you heard from
mr duff's attorney that
ms heard had filed for divorce the
timing
[Music]
of
this
it made me
sick actually it really made me
feel ill it made me
sad frustrated i don't i don't i can't
even find the
word to describe
how i felt when i heard
that the divorce was filed the day after
you know
while i'm at the funeral home
on day two of testimony jurors heard
from isaac baruch a close friend of
depp's and one of the most memorable
witnesses to date
i'm not angry at anybody i want the best
for her for her to take her
responsibility
heal and and and and and
and move on
move on
and and for johnny john you know his
family has been completely wrecked by
all of this stuff and it's not it's it's
it's not
uh
it's
not fair
it's not right what
what she did and what happened
for so many people to get
affected from this
it's
it's insane
tammy was there any testimony that stood
out to you and made you think um i don't
think heard was a victim of domestic
violence in this case
no
no testimony would make me think that i
think that it's just that all the way
around for any victim of domestic
violence this entire situation is
unfortunate because myself being a
survivor of domestic violence and being
a woman that's powerful uh so to speak
it's difficult enough to come forward
but to come forward and then face the
defamation lawsuit of this magnitude is
horrific and to have anyone negate the
um
allegations that that is another form of
abuse in my opinion but there's no
testimony that i heard um that would you
know persuade me one way or the other
even if mr depp was um
a
survivor of domestic violence yeah it's
gonna be interesting to see when depp or
her takes a stand i think that's gonna
be the testimony that swings us one way
or the other
terry we've heard about the depp and
herds relationship but how do you think
depp will connect that to losing these
jobs
well he's claiming that what she said
against him hurt his reputation and
originally in 2016 it hurt his
reputation but it was when that
washington post op-ed came out in
december of 2018
that's when the reputation was really
hurt that's when he lost the disney
pirates franchise and so he me he needs
to make a connection between that
defamation what she said and the lost
wages they've had one witness his sister
so far who sort of made that connection
she said it wasn't because he wasn't
doing well but he needs to show emails
he has to have communication perhaps
some evidence that disney dropped him or
some other movie dropped him and that's
the only way he's going to be able to
show that the false statements
were made that his reputation was
injured yeah i don't know there's a lot
of pirates of the caribbean maybe you
just ended because it ended or maybe it
was because of this of course we'll keep
track as this continues thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you